I've heard my old foe Raymond Blanc is  book signing in town so what better  opportunity to see if I've still got  what it takes  ray white and I go back a long way and  hope he would go a bit of fun with him  he hasn't got the most amazing sense of  humor he's French I'm gonna set myself  three challenges there's no love lost  between us so first can I get him to  sign a book to chef Gordon where's our  song where's the shock wave where's it  blood okay hello mr. blank who uses that  UPS teleprinter it begs water than the  links thank you  well tell yourself would you mean saying  that and doing this  God done he's if chef book-signing done  he hates TV chefs he has a show on TV  currently blessing amazing book I'm  gonna quiz him on that and I know we  don't like t-shirts are you enjoying  being on it yourself no you sent me  expeced you know praise the old yes  awkward question done and finally can I  get a photo for the scrapbook thank you  Thank You Monsieur Blanc done